The first chart I will try is a bar chart.
To do this with Dimple there are a few steps to go through, but
many less than doing this with D3 itself, which we will see later in the lesson.
I want to talk through my coding the editor, before we move back to
the browser and interactively explore what each of these lines does.
The conventions that Dimple works with are axis, series and fields,
which I'll call them here to not confuse them with JavaScript variable, though
they are more closely related to what the grammar of graphics calls variables.
And fields simply refer to columns in our dataset.
Here, attendance is the attendance column.
These three features are the essential building blocks of any chart and
by manipulating each of these we can create a wealth of diverse charts.